heute zeigen wir euch die zahlen auf
deutsch von eins bis 100
los gehts jetzt zeigen wir euch die
zahlen von eins bis zehn
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 gutes versteck
janisch jetzt noch mal langsam
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
[Gelächter]
jetzt zeigen wir euch die zahlen von
zehn bis zwanzig bereit janus 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20
in den zahlen 11 und 12 es gibt es kein
bestimmtes muster aber ab der zahl 13
bis 19
seht ihr immer das gleiche muster man
sieht die drei und die zehen und es wird
kombiniert und die zahl die am ende
steht die wir zuerst gesprochen 3 10 14
jetzt zeigen wir euch wie man im
deutschen die vollen zehn bildet also
die zahlen 20 30 und so weiter dafür
nimmt man immer die erste zahl also die
die ja auch von eins bis zehn
kennengelernt hat und man kombiniert sie
mit zig 20 30 40
40 50 60 70 70 80 90 100
ihr seht manchmal kombiniert man die
ganze zahl 40 40
manchmal gibt es jedoch auch eine
abkürzung der dieser ganzen zahl nämlich
20 man sagt nicht 20 sondern 20 man sagt
auch nicht sechs sondern 60 das klingt
einfach besser im deutschen wenn ihr
noch mehr zu diesem thema üben möchtet
dann laden wir euch ein
ein mitglied von easy german zu werden
als mitglied bekommt ihr jede woche zwei
interaktive übungsblätter zu unseren
videos und diese woche könnt ihr in
unseren übungen die zahlen und auch die
schreibweise der verschiedenen zahlen
üben viel spaß damit
jetzt zeigen wir euch noch die zahlen
über 20 die keine vollen zehner sind und
hier zählt man im deutschen etwas anders
als in anderen ländern
ich sage zum beispiel ich bin 37 jahre
alt 37
hier hat man eine 7 und eine 30 wir
haben beide zahlen gelernt 37 und man
kombiniert die zahlen mit einem und ganz
einfach 37 das interessante ist dass man
immer die hintere zahl
zuerst spricht 37 36 35 54 87 49 88
31 83 99 2 eur 49 1 euro 54 21 moskito
bis 22 moskito bis 23 moskito bis 24 25
26 27 28 29
mosquito besser wenn ihr gerade anfangs
deutsch zu lernen und noch mehr videos
sehen möchtet dann subscribe to
unbedingt unseren kanal jeden mittwoch
bringen wir ein video in unserer reihe
super easy german raus wo wir speziell
videos für anfänger machen und wir haben
auch eine ganze playlist hier unten
verlinkt wo man videos sehen kann
für alle von euch die gerade anfangen
gerne laden wir euch auch ein ein
mitglied zu werden von easy german damit
unterstützt ihr unsere arbeit und
gleichzeitig unterstützt ihr euer
deutsch lernen und bekommt jede woche
transkripte vokabel listen und viele
interaktive übungen tschüss und bis bald
ich bin zurück 98 96 97 98 91 100 hallo
schatz